رساله وحده من البيت الابيض الى روسيا عند
استقباله للمستشار الالماني اولا فشولز
شكر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الزعيم
الالماني على دعمه لاوكرانيا بعد تردد
الاخير في ارسال دبابات لكيف
وعدنا معا بالرد واوفينا بوعدنا لقد عززتم
الدعم
ثابته قدمنا لاوكرانيا جميع المساعدات
العسكريه بارسال ذخيره والمدفعيه
والدبابات المدرعه وانظمه الدفاع الجوي
بصفتنا حلفاء في الناتو فاننا نجعل
التحالف اقوى بكثير
مساله تسليم الدبابات الالمانيه كانت مصدر
توتر بين واشنطن وبرلين لكن بعد ضغط
امريكي وافقت المانيا اخيرا في السادس
والعشرين من يناير على ارسال عدد من
دباباتها من طراز الايوباردي الى اوكرانيا
في هذه الزياره الثانيه
على اهميه استمرار دعمك في حربها ضد موسكو
من المهم حقا ان عمل بخطوات ثابته لتقديم
الدعم اللازم لاوكرانيا
سنواصل دعمها طالما كان ذلك ضروريا
تثير هذه الزياره حفيظه الكريم الذي حذر
قبل اجتماع من ان ارسال شحنات اسلحه غربيه
جديده لاوكرانيا لن يؤدي الا الى اطاله
النزاع لقاء بيض واشولز ياتي ايضا لتوجيه
رساله غير مباشره للصين بحسب مسؤولين
امريكيين فان البيت الابيض بدا التشاور مع
الحلفاء بشان فرد عقوبات محتمله على الصين
اذا قدمت بكين دعما عسكريا لروسيا في
حربها على اوكرانيا